if I want something I go into the future
in my brain which is powerful and I
visualize exactly what I want and then I
think about every single thing I need to
do to make that happen and every single
thing that could stop that from
happening what I need to avoid then I go
right back like I was just in the future
thinking about watching myself on my
television network because I do that
that means I have to think what would be
the worst case scenario and then I have
to think what would be the best case
scenario and then I eliminate every
single thing that I think Could Happen
which I call Art detecting and then I
put everything and every single attitude
and person around me in my vision that's
going to make me get to what I want and
also I try to get the people around me
to think about the same exact Vision so
even inspire people and all that energy
is focused on one thing that they can
visualize in their head then it becomes
a tangible reality and I know that to be
a fact because it's happened it's a fact
for me so I continue to do that I am
really careful about how small my
thoughts are because I don't feel like
wasting time in a 24-hour day making
this much and I could spend the same
amount of time with the same amount of
energy if an art detective right at this
much and with this much I can can help
so many more people that I love need
motivation what's your top 10 with
police Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because you
you person any
angle but you know you're capable of
more and you get that Push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today this one from one of the best Dame
Dash and my take on his top 50 rules for
Success enjoy
people were just slaves to pattern yeah
like if everyone does one thing then
everybody else wants to do it and I'm a
guy that never wants to and ever I never
ever wanted to look like everybody else
right so my thing is I gotta stand up I
gotta be different all right got some
harlems is that is it I think it's just
you know it is because again like when
you make money really young right it
makes you really confident and sometimes
people mistake it as arrogance but like
when you're in the circumstance where
you have no choice but to grow up and
it's very competitive it wasn't like I
was the only young dude getting money
right everybody that was in my age in a
certain circle was getting money so it
was normal right to conduct yourself
like an adult and then you were kind of
Guided by adults right so I just got
used to a different pattern really young
and it was more of a freedom pattern
that came with the survival and wanting
to be the best at it how is it being
so-called so unpopular to make sure that
others around you were popular the funny
thing is number one I don't care right
right well number two I feel very
popular at all times right right
the thing that people understand I'm not
a rapper not a singer not an actor you
know I'm a businessman so the fact that
anyone even cares to me whether they
don't like it or do like it it I mean on
a business level or for a big picture
guy that's really all that counts like
on a personal level there's social
classes right so there's one class
that's meant to work for those that
don't work and those that don't work are
usually second and third generation
they're born into it the reason why is
those people own things and they pass it
yeah so what they do is they give
another class the working class
distractions make them hate each other
make them want to do Sports and only
know how to do like what's a lotto like
we're only programmed to say the only
way we could get out of a social class
to be workers is to be athletes or to be
entertainers and that and that slide is
like Lotto but even in school they
distract you and say Here's every team
that can go professional but there's no
like political team they never show you
how to be a politician or how to change
a law or they have singing class and all
this other everything to distract you so
and that's a lot of to win at that level
right so that means everyone that's
trained their whole life to get there
which is 90 of the world which is the
working class only one percent gets
there and that
person that was an Entertainer or you
know they get to get into the one
percent but only if they sell out and
distract everyone else that they were a
part of that helped them get where they
got to go and I'm just not down for that
pattern and it's strategic it's not like
the way nerds people that aren't strong
control you know people that are strong
like be like whatever like jump in front
of me I fight but people that are weak
they have to be strategic about how they
control so brain controls muscle and
that's what's been happening we've been
controlled we've been programmed to hate
each other kill each other be happy to
have a job happy to work for someone
else and only happy to be able to take
care of yourself so everybody comes from
a place of self-preservation everyone's
always worried about themselves so and
the purpose of love is to love people
before you love yourself but now look at
the way the system is set up
in school they take your kids from you
and then they tell you unless you go to
college and this is you know the
majority of the world
and the majority of the world is the
working class unless you go to college
what you can't afford unless you get a
loan to go to college you've done
something wrong so you go to college you
get that loan and in order to pay off
the loan you got to get a job you don't
want and you're still desperate and in
order to buy that house because you paid
that loan you ain't got no cash now you
got to get a loan another loan to get
the house so you always have to be
working from backwards you always have
to be worried about yourself and what I
find when I'm around desperate people is
they they're all right with with yo I
got to do what I got to do they they
sometimes justify doing things that are
not honorable to survive so you know
everyone's always in a place of fear a
place of back pedaling and
self-preservation and that's the problem
the test is to love others before you
love yourself and that's what a real
boss does the test is to think about the
future not the present your presence is
only dictated by what you did in your
past so you got to start planning this
chess not Checkers what is your
definition of a cultural term
a person that makes money from the
culture but doesn't live the culture a
person that doesn't help the culture
that they're making money from a person
that intentionally hurts the money the
culture so that they can monetize it a
person that takes care of their children
based on somebody else's work and their
labor and makes them think they have
more than they do so that they can
continue to work for them a person that
makes you believe you're dependent on
them that you need them to get from
point A to point B just so you can
monetize it that's a culture vulture and
that could be black white whatever
there's black codes of OJ there's white
culture vultures there's every kind of
nationality and the worst culture
vulture is the one that does it within
his own supposed culture that's the one
that's the devil because he's pretending
to be something he's not and that's
cheating also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
well I tell my staff and everyone that
works with me is
the more you care the more you prepare
period and thinking is a part of that
you'd be surprised how many people are
scared to think most of my arguments
don't come from me pushing somebody
physically it's from me pushing them to
think about God damn you don't want to
think like that doesn't eat like it's
harder to run a mile than to think so
why is it less scary to work out than to
just think
and it doesn't take any physical effort
it's about a perspective why are people
so scared of the unknown
just because you don't know when
answered like Google was so foreign to
me up to a couple years ago as
surprising as that may seem but Raquel
who's wifey for life he remembers the
moment that I was like holy [ __ ]
find out everything all this time you
know all I would have had to do was
and I would have seen how easy it was
but because it was unknown in the moment
I thought it was complicated how many
times do you get a remote control it
does three million things but just
because you don't know how you can't
figure it out you're like all those
other things even though if you look at
it it will make life a bit easier my
purpose was to let everybody else eat
that wasn't anything that deserved to
and to believe the bully oppressed the
oppressor and always give us
self-awareness not one second that I was
in the music industry did I ever act
like I wanted to be with the people that
were exploiting the artist right the
problem always was with the executives
was I was like nah you're not doing that
to the artist and then you know what an
executive will do is play dirty and
snarky and go start lying and do things
that you wouldn't do or expect to do
when they just start to make a division
between you and the person you're
protecting by saying you'll get more
money by not listening to them when
actually that money goes to them I think
the truth is most important and I think
it's inexcusable not to tell it and I
think if there's something on your mind
on a truthful level as a grown-up you
should be able to articulate that and
sometimes people don't like what you say
but it doesn't mean it shouldn't be said
right so you know nine times out of ten
a man that's full of testosterone that's
I mean in front of girls you know if you
tell them how to improve themselves or
give them some instructive criticism
they tend to take that as you try to
make them look bad because they want to
look better than you I decided to hit
the street because I just wanted to buy
a Suzuki
they cost ten thousand and I didn't have
a license and my mother didn't want to
buy it for me because it wasn't legal so
I was like well I just got to get that
myself and you know crack came out so I
was watching a lot of people my age have
things that adults had which gave them a
certain amount of Independence like if
you're paying your own bills I don't
care how old you are no one can tell you
what to do period
and that's what I tell anyone of my
children the minute you pay your own
bills all I could do is give you advice
but I can't control your environment
so when I got to this place
the only way to survive
was honor and what I witnessed I admired
I admired the strength and honor because
honor isn't convenient
it's not I'm honorable when it's easy
honor comes when it's not easy that's
your definition that's the test that's
what defined you is when you have the
choice to not be honorable and it would
appear that you'll get something and
life may be easier
and if you choose honor and you choose a
harder path when you know which you
really are and that's what that is all
day it's a test all day there's always
these shortcuts but the thing about
being in that life is you make one
mistake you die you make one mistake you
lose your life in jail your freedom
you make one mistake people you love get
hurt like kidnapped and tortured
so logically speaking to survive that
you have to be honorable
and I saw the the things that the Arnold
the respect that came with it the
strength that came with it and how cool
it looked I just didn't want to be
anything but that no matter what
and everyone that's practiced that my
friends 20 30 years later like in honor
up that's really my OG that's really the
guy that taught me those principles
that's the voice I heard it from
and imagine 30 years later
him being able to say I told you be
honorable and you'll get this and it
happened for him it happened for me and
all the other people that have lived
honorably
so there's truth in believing and honor
and I can say it by experience
and I also can see the lack of Honor the
things that I came up on that are so
different that how much people look the
other way how many people actually fail
that test and the recourse of that
the unhappy life that comes with the
perception of being happy of looking
like you have more than you do or that
you're smarter tougher richer funnier or
anything that you pretend you are and
you're not
because it tortures that person they all
look for an escape whether it's a drug
or any kind of addiction to just not
face and look in the mirror to not to be
able to look at yourself in the mirror
or take that shower that must suck but I
don't know how that feels I know how it
feels to have no conscience to look in
the mirror be alone and be like I'm real
happy about every single decision I make
a bunch of unthorable people a million
unthorable people can't do nothing to
one thorough person I don't care what it
looked like I'm here and I look better
than anybody else I've been talking
about I'm doing better than everybody
else up and talk about me and I've been
fighting on my own it ain't no
announcements I give you that work I
don't even have to be like then I'm
still here or it might be look like I'm
not like but they still buying it see in
the street you don't like the drug
dealer you like his drugs you don't care
if he's nice you don't care he doesn't
promote his drugs he he's not saying
thank you for buying he says get in line
I'm not taking fives only twenties and
if you talk too cute to me I won't sell
to it when I get out of here you don't
have to be nice when your work is good
you just have to be honorable and
respectful and the people I'm not nice
to deserve it the reason why people take
jobs is because they got to pay their
bills right but me like I don't mind
paying bills a little late you know what
I'm saying I'm gonna own it I just
rather I'd rather struggle a little you
know what I'm saying if it's late it's
late but when I got it I pay it you know
what I'm saying and I pay a lot of it so
you know it's just like the difference
between corporate and like an individual
is Corporate has money to lose so in any
business you lose money for like 10
years that's what happens it's because
you have a big pocket so you could lose
it and be comfortable like anybody could
buy a celebrity but how much profit are
you really making it's like walking up
to a dice game and you got the most
money in your pocket you just keep
stopping the bank so you might lose lose
but you keep betting it all betting it
all you lose lose and then when you you
know eventually hey crack is going to
happen or you're going to ace you're
gonna win get all your money back and be
up that's business but you know
corporate they have a pocket it's not
their money it's a fund they go get
other people's money it's stock is
public so they could lose like when I
when like business plans they'll be like
lose two million for this year lose two
men like 10 years to lose you if you
have a deep pocket for that you could be
in corporate business but an independent
doesn't have that kind of money to lose
you understand what I'm saying they
can't just take losses you can't just be
hiring people paying them and you ain't
making no money right you understand
what I'm saying you count everything
when you're doing it independently but
so what you know not to say fidels
Castro's virtues and know what he
believed in as far as you know the
communism thing but he basically said
forget I'm gonna be independent and I
just do it myself I'll just be a little
behind but you know Independence is
priceless I think the test and the
reason why I continually keep getting
tested with people keep treating me
unfair is to see if I will lose faith in
people but I'll never lose faith in
people I always try to invest in things
and people that inspire me regardless
because my agenda is not really to rob
it was just I'm actually getting
something out of it so [ __ ] what are you
getting it's pretty interesting because
you've had experience the The Experience
like I said if somebody makes a record
and it's a historic record and I was in
there while it was made how many people
would pay to be in the room with Jimi
Hendrix when he made you know Purple
Haze would you yeah I would so I've been
in that room a lot I've been in the room
people I got paid to be in a room that
people would pay to be in while his
history was made like you know Biggie
Smalls is a friend was a friend of mine
still is he said my name in raps
wouldn't you have paid for that to be in
the studio with Biggie or old dirty
bastard
I was in the studio with them or be in
the studio with puff when he wrote when
when Source wrote Every Step eat the
sting record I was there there's so many
historic moments the money doesn't mean
it's the experience people read the
Bible sometimes I think they get the
message a little misconstrued like you
know the way Jesus went down was he
sacrificed himself for his kids right
right so his kids didn't have to feel
his pain right right so I looked at that
like number one if you're a good guy
you're getting hung up on a cross but
number two you got to feel some pain so
that the people you love don't right and
and it just happened from God on down
people expect me to get punched in the
faces not to beat somebody's ass if I
get smacked I'm punching period there's
a time and a place for everything but
the majority in my life as you all see
I'm laughing I'm happy when I get in the
ring I'm I'm just a Fearless ferocious
fighter I want that smoke that that
so-called scared the business what
business just like you know the
entertainment I'm not in that business
she went into different vibrations I'm
not in the soldier business I'm in the
general business I'm not in the slave
mentality business I'm in the master
mentality business we playing two
different games when I look at something
I don't say yo how do I buy it I say how
do I make it you feel me when I when I
look at I'm gonna make a TV show I gotta
have a network I'm not making a record I
gotta have you know I don't look at
things in that variation I can't I never
have I don't look at nickels I only look
at weight
I can't see nickels I can't talk
Nicholas Define what you consider
wealthy well there's happiness
completely is how much you laugh and how
much the people you love laugh and
that's really what love is and how much
time you spend like sending money back
to somebody like a child it's not
considered love because kids don't care
about money I remember when I was a
child all I wanted for Christmas was for
my parents for my mom to get back with
my dad
and I didn't I wasn't able to give that
to my any one of my children so I still
have work to do
you know
I haven't hit that wealthiness because I
haven't been able to take that most
important pain to a child
and take that away from my children I
haven't broke that cycle that would be
well
if my children don't have to pick a side
if they don't have to watch us fight if
they don't have to tune out because they
don't want to hear us argue
you know what I'm saying what's going to
be the secret there
finding the right woman for the right
reasons
so it's great because I was very really
able to recognize it in Raquel that I
was like nah this time
I'm staying we're doing everything
together like she's I I enjoyed this too
much so it's always looking at it from
my kids perspective my woman's
perspective it's I think I've learned to
take my eyeballs out of my head and put
it in theirs for a second to see what
they see and what would make them
comfortable over me as a boss
your job is to think about your business
and your staff before you think about
yourself it's the same thing a a dad
does or the head of a family
so
I guess me being conscious of these
things at 47 being involved enough to
take the time to appreciate that that's
to me as well
you know uncompromised great quality of
living like
I prefer not to have to live in a house
that's not big and all the luxuries that
I've worked so hard to get
but I think
every circumstance Raquel and I have
been in we've been equally happy whether
it's a big house or a studio apartment
the thing that we haven't as a culture
been able to do is practice nepotism we
haven't been able to pass offices but
I'm proud when I walk in to my spot and
I got different buildings and then I go
into your spot yeah you got a building
right right we got our own companies
yeah and our children can walk and do
what they want and work just like they
do for them and it's not a color thing
it's a it's a mentality thing you know
what I'm saying as a mentality we have
to understand we're supposed to help
each other we're supposed to push each
other forward we're supposed to evolve
each other we're supposed to stick
together we're supposed to why don't we
Dame why because people are insecure
they think it's easier to pretend than
to really do it is our culture insecure
though human human nature is insecure
everybody fights it's not just us that
fight each other right the whole world
fights each other our whole mentality is
slavery everyone has an apartment right
you're the boss in your apartment right
no matter what no matter how little it
is if it's whether it's a big house or a
little house that space right there
you're the boss that's what your
business is that's what your life is you
create the space so you can control it
you control your environment but you
have to Art detect that you want to live
in a house build it you know what I'm
saying nobody gonna give it to you but
once you get in that house I don't care
if the president or whoever it is anyway
you walk in my house Obama you still got
to listen to me in this house it means
nothing I'm the boss here so you create
your own house you do what you want make
sure you enjoy it and then you pay you
get paid for it as you sell it you got
to work harder than everybody else but
it's something you can pass to your
children it's just about controlling
your environment right but working a
little hard harder to do so like people
think it's safe to have a job but if
somebody could find you how is that safe
right you know what I'm saying period
like you got to be nice to somebody if
they don't like you they can fire you
and if they the people that can fire you
don't be owning this neighbor they'd be
supervisors so then it becomes like
political there's no politics when
you're in the boss it's my wait or no
way I'm the boss you don't take your
shoes off in my house you don't come in
my house period I show people based on
what I go through what not to do you
know I don't hide nothing
you know I've chosen I've signed on to
making money with the people not
um from the people with the people I'm
rich Everybody Eats when I eat Everybody
Eats and everyone will tell you that
that's the problem like if I help 100
dudes and 10 run off a height but I'm
not going out the other 90. it's always
going to be Thieves insecure people that
want to pretend they did something that
they didn't they always do well that's
why guys like Brian White and Josh Weber
and Mike Munster try to pretend they
directed my movie and I made it because
I did something so cheap and so good
that they were like oh I got to have
this and then they want to paint a
picture like they always try to make a
good guy look bad just so that they
don't look bad but you know what happens
these people are weak it doesn't matter
what people think it doesn't matter what
people say it doesn't matter all that
matters is what they do all that matters
is action everybody always worry about
my tone worry about with my action
what's my action what I say what do I do
now everybody want to talk nice but
don't do [ __ ] anybody want to talk about
things but don't have any solutions but
they talk so militantly but they're just
saying what's popular opinion what they
have no Solutions I come with a solution
and I fight Frontline like a king
because a king fights with everybody I
fight I don't never send somebody do
something I wouldn't do myself I'm about
that action I gotta be I gotta lead by
example why did the death of your mom
affect you so much and exactly how did
it affect you
well number one at that age it was the
only thing I was scared of and it
happened
so once why did it scare you I mean
because that's what I love my mother
more than anything you know I was a kid
that went to camp and was homesick you
know when she went out and came home
late I would be like you know let's
choose all I had my mom you know I was
an only child
from my mom's
so when she died you know and for a
child what more do you have to be scared
of right
so when she died I had faced my worst
nightmare so right there I was Fearless
I just wasn't scared of nothing I just
felt like if anything happened to me I
would just get to my mom quicker and at
the time I had no kids so it wasn't
really like I had anybody to worry about
but me
but then also I was like but if I'm
gonna be on this planet I'm gonna have
to you know take care of myself just as
good as my mother took care of me so at
that point I had no choices you know I
had to make money to eat
you know I had to make money to to live
and and buy clothes you know what I'm
saying there's no option either she was
gonna make me great or I was gonna make
me great either way I was gonna be dang
that some of us acting like bosses right
but some of us really are right some of
us looking like bosses right but some of
us really are [ __ ] if you're a boss
where's your office and it better be
yours you better be paying the rent
right you see some piano let me see you
pay some employees let me see you for a
second cause you ain't collect no bread
you know what that 30 is all of that
type right if you're a boss you know
about pain and all that you know about
paying people before yourself right all
that you know about every time you start
a new business like when you make a
movie and and like we make movies yeah
I'm gonna take to get the money back
the thing about how the [ __ ] is like
everyone knows like this kid puts his
own money up even for his own movie a
man of his own yeah but he's broke yeah
you know I'm broke because I got money
and equity in businesses like I don't
want to drop records I drop I drop
businesses you understand what I'm
saying like I sell companies like [ __ ]
sell records that's my game I play a
different game right right so when they
say how many records you so I don't know
how many how many companies I saw
Rockaway I saw Rockefeller I sell
companies there's men that don't sell
companies their whole life don't know
whatever they sell records don't sell
companies and I do bars but it's true
you know I mean that's like a real fact
you know what I mean yeah yeah and every
time I sell one that means I started
from scratch that means I had to be
broke I had to feel some pain I had to
lose sustained look [ __ ] up and then
go sell it and make them some bread pay
off some bills and start again there it
is and you flip because I learned that
from the street like yo I could buy
something for twenty dollars and sell it
for 40. right you know if I break it
down I buy something for 40 break it
down right that's just what I did I made
a record company so that I could do a
clothing company a clothing company so I
could do a television network right Flip
Flip Flip next I'm gonna flip fourth
okay and you're gonna keep going you
it's hard to keep a real boss down now
well nobody never been down here that's
the thing they could make you look a
certain way right but bottom line is you
I don't know man I I like when I do my
Instagram I'm not outside I'm in the
house I'm in my office all right I'm not
trying to front I'm not posing like my
natural life looks like a movie right so
at any time I've never had a problem I
ran around the world and opened up
galleries all over the world like I got
dd172 when Tribeca poppington and Lower
East Side I got one in Burbank one in uh
Hong Kong po Hong Kong no one ever wants
to talk about that right all the
cultural things I'm the DNA of what I
want the culture to be at some point and
I want us to be tasteful I want us to be
evolved right I want us to deal with
things like men not emotion right I want
us to really be rich not look rich I
want us to be friends I want us to stick
together I want us to take care of our
kids I want us to take care of women I
want that to be cool I want selling out
to be suckers I want looking other way
to be sucker and what treating women bad
to be suckers right with little girls to
be suckers I don't want people to be
with people even though they do do stuff
looking the other way gotta stop you got
to be accountable why you know he's
scared to have them conversations dang
why can't I see you you ask me about
fear and I don't even know what that is
the only thing I fear is fear so you
asking me about a concept I don't
understand that's not that's no bueno
that's not even because cats don't want
to talk people will hide and just follow
us when you speak people like when you
speak boss you don't understand fear
what language is that fear what does
that mean right you know what I'm saying
what what is that you got to translate
that to me I don't even what is that I'm
never understood I don't speak fear
what does that mean you know what I'm
saying like if your boss fear doesn't
even come into it what I do is I'm a
businessman right in any business the
more crowded it is the harder it is to
do it so I never want to hustle on a
crowded block so regardless of what I'm
always looking to do something that
nobody's doing so while I was looking is
was what's the next wave logically it
was just logically I was paying
attention you know what I'm saying so
once I realized that I was like it's the
internet like I came up with no internet
internet no emails no nothing like I had
to pay for Real Estate to be seen on
like you know cable TV or radio but this
Freedom was ridiculous and plus like it
was like damn if I know how to make this
myself like content is like currency
it's the thing that makes money forever
and ever so it's like it's like when
somebody smokes a joint the weed is gone
you got to grow more weed when somebody
looks at something you can pay over and
over again to see it and you ain't got
to keep making it so if you make
something that people see plus when you
make content it's a commercial for
everything you understand so I just look
at what people pay for and do it myself
I'm the plug I'm never a customer on any
level so I just look at it from that
approach so I look for the future hustle
and how to beat a plug at it and then
from that it all falls into pieces it
made sense with the internet that people
would be buying content it made sense
with the internet like oh [ __ ] we could
cut out the middleman it made sense with
the internet that if I have a voice I
could be heard uncensored I'm used to
complete censorship so it made sense to
do it on my own I did all of it on my
own without this [ __ ] so could you
imagine what I'm gonna do with this I
just I started sitting by the pool and
smoking weed it was like I gotta slow
down I think when you have Consciousness
you become responsible
you know and I think the truth is a
heavy burden because usually the truth
teller gets gets crucified like Jesus
you know the person that tells the truth
is always going to have to fight the
people that are lying and because the
people that are lying or cheating
you're not fighting the same fight like
that they'll do you won't do so how do
you protect yourself you got to be extra
strong you got to be like Batman you got
to be like a superhero but look that as
a criminal it's a life you got to choose
and that's the life that I did choose
because life has been so easy for me
I've had so much fun every second I've
benefited and monetized my my everything
that I love at every time you know I'm
47 years old I'll be 47 in May I what
else should I do you know what I'm
saying like and plus I don't like the
people that are taking advantage in
front and I think they're soft and I
want everybody to know so that's why I
call out names like Leo Cohen and
Charlie walk and Barry Barry uh
clock thinking about Barry clauberg you
know Steve Stout all of those people
that I feel have done that and have
really taken advantage I think I don't
want other people to get taken advantage
of
so that's like if you see a child
molester in the neighborhood it's your
responsibility to say yo don't have your
kids around them and I love my culture
like they're my children they're not my
children I'm not being that cocky but we
are family so I'm gonna look out for my
cousins and my family at all times if
you had to sum up the your message about
life what would you say
I mean you know
my name's Dame Dash right
and uh with this the dash in between the
beginning of when you born you died at
Dash that's the life that's your life so
I think
we're here to live we're here to learn
you know I'm not here to be perfect
we're supposed to embrace all our
imperfections
and I think if we find and can imagine
the bright side and anything that will
become a reality
but you can't think anything's going to
be given to you other than opportunity
and the only way to show appreciation
for opportunities to react not to say
thank you but to actually do something
and not everyone gets opportunities
so I think appreciating those
opportunities is really important
because
the next time those opportunities will
not be presented and I think every
single day for everybody
there's a lesson
there's a test
and if you don't pass the test you do
not move forward
you stay in the same place
and then that test becomes a little
harder and if you don't pass it again
you actually go backwards and then
instead of the test being in front of
you where you could look at the test and
sit back at you and it's smacking the
[ __ ] out of you in the back of your head
and it hurts and it's embarrassing
so I always advise people to look out
for those tests not the ones when people
are looking just when no one's looking
the final
finally it's someone that exploits a
culture and benefits from a culture that
it doesn't help you know period that it
just hurts and it just sucks out
everything from it but it could give a
[ __ ] about it that's a culture vulture
you know and and it happens more times
than not I mean I mean it's all over the
place well creative people usually
aren't so right well creative people
usually aren't so worried about
monetization you know they want to pay
their bills but non-creative people are
solely making money off of a creative
and they don't get the creative people I
mean and it means they come they kind of
have to Rob them I first got record
deals and I didn't like the experience
of it you know they were they were
telling me I just it didn't work out and
I had Jay-Z I had Jay-Z and I was
shopping Jay-Z and they were every
single person in the music business I
took them to every single label and they
told me he was too old too corny nothing
just damn near laugh me out every one of
them could not see where he was so we
had to do it ourselves sure so off top
we kind of because when you're the plug
in the street you think like the plug
everywhere yeah so I'm thinking who's
the boss here who do I need to talk to
there is no boss in corporate because no
one really owns it it's public so I was
like I got to do this on my own so we
did it on our own so knowing that we had
the best rapper on the planet knowing
that these were the lanes that were
making no decisions that that business
model never worked for us so we decided
to make our own business model and do it
on our own where we never had to
compromise any Integrity or any or
compromise of equity I would love to
know what your outlook is when you in
your past have had a setback how do you
ever had a setback but death okay that's
the only setback is health and death in
jail other than that those are just life
tests so like what's a setback like if a
friend comes to you and they feel like
they failed at something what would you
tell them to change that perspective of
the word failure turn a loss into a
learning experience do it again until
you get it right period you never did
anything right the first time practice
makes perfect it's just like you ain't
gonna make a muscle the first time you
pick up a ball you gotta do that [ __ ]
and do it for a while then your blood
pumps and then you strong go strong pull
your skirt up that's what I'm gonna say
I'm not going to be nice about it I'm
sick of that everybody's depressed
because they're trying to fit into a
puzzle they're trying to be a circle in
a square and you you're told what to do
and you're told what to eat and you're
told what's good and bad and what's the
perspective of successes success is love
success is your family successes if how
much you laugh I don't care how much
money you got in the bank if you got a
crooked smile if you're people around
you don't want to be around your breaths
things and all that other [ __ ] you're
broke period right you're broke if you
have nothing to fight for you're broke
you have nothing to love you broke
period what are some key elements of
your honor code that one are just
absolutely Central to it and that too if
you could pass to the culture in an
instant what would you pass
I mean if you have an agreement with
somebody if me and you have an agreement
I don't care what the rest of the world
looks at as bad or good we have to honor
our agreement
period so honor means that when you
agree and you guys have as men or a
professional
an adult
your word guided me more than anything
you know if you say you're going to do
something you gotta do it
and that's what the street kind of was
you know it was like even though the
rest of the world doesn't believe in
certain things that were going on
there was this cold
you know no snitching
you know no messing with your homies
girls
no serving anyone pregnant you know just
things that were laws that were
Unwritten you know
but there was honor
honor means more than anything bro and
it protects you no matter what and I
could just say that based on my
experience there ain't no streaks
that's just some real the street Mighty
like I'm a guy that maybe I need to see
some
to learn honor and maybe that's the
reason why I was put in that situation
because once I learned honor I'd be able
to affect the rest of the world like you
never know why things happen
that's about perspective right what do
you do like just to relax I mean you're
always running what do you do to like
just other than the kids just is there
someone you meditate I smoke weed I lay
by the pool a lot good like you know
this is cool like I wasn't here all day
you know what I'm saying I came in when
I felt like it I went and got my
daughter came back went back you know I
was playing it's living life but I'm
doing it on my terms right you know I'm
doing it like like I'm I'm productive
but I'm not tired because I'm when
you're doing what you love like
everything I'm doing I would do for free
this like I'm lucky enough that I can
monetize what people do for recreation
you know what I'm saying so how can I
have a complain and be tired I'm having
way too much fun to be tight have you
ever watched a James Bond movie where it
doesn't look like he's losing at some
point and then he wins or Batman or Iron
Man or any superhero there has to be
some diversity for you to you know
overcome to win you know you can't be a
champ unless you uh you know are in a
place where you look like you're gonna
lose and then you win the pain that's
going to come with being independent you
have to embrace it because it's going to
happen and also know that the more
successful you get the more problems
you're going to have the more knots
you're gonna have to untie being a boss
does not mean smooth sailing it means
having the ability to care about other
people before yourself and to untie
problems untie knots that's all it is
there's it's not business if there's not
a problem there's nothing good without
struggle it just doesn't happen in all
my experiences there hasn't been one
thing that's been successful without me
feeling some pain before it was
successful so now when there is pain I
embrace it you know I've been embracing
it I'm a G about it because I know that
must mean that if I'm cool that you know
would awaits me like the darkest before
the dawn I don't I don't want to like
sound corny but that's really what
that's that's what has to happen one day
and yeah my mom's died it broke my heart
but on the other hand it made me great
it's about perspective what I learned
from it how I choose to look at it
you know
like sometimes I'll talk to somebody
and you know they'll be abusive or
they'll be drinking they'll be like you
know what if you do all that drinking
why are you so abusive oh my dad was
drinking he was abusive that's all I
know then you ask somebody else and
they're like a straight Square they
don't drink and they're not abusive and
you'd be like yo how come you don't
drink how come you're not abusive yo I
saw my dad
it's just about perspective
you know that's how I look at things
with my pops I was like I know I'm a
good dad because everything he did I
didn't like I ain't doing in my kid I'm
not going to pass the cycle but you know
some people might look at it and say I'm
just gonna pass the cycle because he
passed it to me
perspective how did you apply the stuff
from the street to the business World
well let me explain it to you so when
you deal with a bunch of people that are
tamed and you're a wild animal you get
in a room you laugh at them you don't be
scared of them I always thought they
were a joke because I had executed
business under a different circumstances
so I always thought they were funny and
also because they were working for other
people and I was putting up my own money
I didn't really respect as much like you
know a boss wants to talk to another
boss so it made me know not to be
corporate when I went into that world I
went very arrogantly I didn't feel like
because I was always ahead of the game I
got my first deal at 19. you know what I
mean so I felt like the people that I
was dealing with shouldn't even be
talking to me a certain way even telling
me was cool because they were nerdy to
me when we were leveraging in that point
was cool I was selling music swag I was
coming from the authentic Street like in
the 80s so it wasn't nothing that you
could tell me and then I had a mind
because I was educated so I saw them
trying to trick me into believing I was
dumber than I was so for that I was a
beast it was it was just like it was a
joke you know what I mean so I did it we
just did it on our own so you took it
personally but you were offended I mean
it sounds like you're offended I mean
I'm passionate about everything I'm due
this is about creative business okay so
of course when someone disrespects your
intellect you take it personal I'm a man
I got testosterone for sure but that's
part of being an entrepreneur you know
what I'm saying but also I'm coming from
a place where I had to fight for my real
estate and prove that you shouldn't have
it so certain kinds of people can never
talk to me a certain way you understand
what I'm saying just because they didn't
they weren't men like I was men again
they weren't taking they weren't putting
up their own money they didn't have the
cool and they weren't doing what I was
doing it was like I knew always my worth
at all times and I always knew what my
brain was capable of doing I come from a
very extreme circumstance you know I
come like Frontline streets like 142nd
and Linux and if you did break any of
those laws you died or went to jail so I
didn't have too many choices so I don't
really know no different you know what I
mean so I just applied everything I
learned from my survival skills and
obviously I survived and I came again
from a very dangerous place I survived
it just by being honorable playing the
game right being loyal and I was like yo
this game right here is not sustainable
[ __ ] died being honorable means you
got to kill when they disrespect you you
got to go to jail and not you know all
that type that's not a game I want to
play I'm gonna just take these ideals
and apply them instead of to crack apply
it to music instead of to dust apply it
to Fashion it's just taking the same
principles and applying and everything
I've learned really has come from
hustling it's just flip it you know you
buy something you you you you you bottle
it up you sell it you make double and
then you put that back and you keep
doing it so once you know that
discipline why else do you need why do
you need anybody like I never wanted
anybody to hit me with no work I didn't
I never wanted that what I saw in
Kanye's face when he was helping us is
something that people don't get
when you help people that deserves it it
gives you a really good feeling
it makes you feel better than anything I
saw him smiling and laughing and I was
like he gets it now because that's how I
feel every time I help somebody get
where they got to go and you know I did
it just because I wanted to just because
I was inspired not because I was trying
to exploit him but just because I really
liked who they were and what they were
doing
and I want that to be a contagious
energy and I really hope that overall
that's what honor rub does it makes
honor up beat a new wave looking out for
the people that looked out for you doing
the right thing I'm a very sophisticated
guy you know I mean I have good taste
right and I've always loved art and only
thing you need to make a gallery is
walls so you know instead it's just a
narrative I call it a gallery it's a
gallery and I put art on it and people
come in if they buy the art I get 50 of
them that's the art business but what it
does is it brings very artistic people
together so you know art brings all
kinds of creatives together actually I
always have a collective so because when
someone's good at editing they're
usually good at a lot of other things
somebody's good at rapping or singing
they're good at acting they're good at
painting like creators are just
creatives and you know sometimes people
only do what they think they can do if
you don't know the business you just say
oh I can't do it so I don't just like an
art gallery see me I'm always thinking
on how to do it and usually not that
hard and then also look at who does it
and I compare myself right yeah like you
can do it do you think bosses are born
or are they made
I think everyone has the potential to be
a boss I think you are born a boss and
made a slave no one's going to choose to
be a slave who the [ __ ] want to be a
slave you got to be trained and think
that life is good when it's not
um
yeah you want to boss until somebody
convinces you you're not yeah I'm born
the boss if I could breathe and I'm
controlling that I'm a boss and anything
I own is mine no matter who you are you
cannot come in here unless if I'm not
breaking no laws do not come in here and
if you do it's on my terms are you
breaking the law
you know and I could be confident
arrogant about that as long as I'm not
breaking the laws I just don't see the
reason for being mad about making
mistakes like I just I just
I don't know man
I think I got yelled at one time when I
was four and I felt embarrassed and I
didn't like that feeling
so I did what the guy did with the cold
I figured out how to never be
embarrassed you know what I'm saying
Teach me how you just don't give a [ __ ]
once you don't give a [ __ ] what people
think like logically speaking why would
you care about what someone's opinion is
that you don't love that doesn't love
you that's not even playing the same
game you're playing that's only you know
the only reason why they have something
to say is because they're insecure
like I don't I just I don't see why I
would be concerned about some insecure
[ __ ]
like I I think one million Lanes
combined cannot equal one cool person
and meaning someone that's just honest
about who they are
like being it's not relatable it's not
realistic to think that anyone is
perfect and anyone that is is evil
because it's just not true you know what
I'm saying
and the good thing about imperfections
is what makes you cool is how you deal
with them that's what makes you cool
you know what I'm saying so I've never
been afraid to be wrong I always
remember back to when I was young
laughing at older [ __ ] I'm never going
to be that older [ __ ] I was laughing at
I'm never gonna be that old man in the
club I'm never going to be the dude that
you know just because that one time I
wore that outfit everyone thought I was
fly I'm aware for the next 30 Years like
I'm not doing that you know what I'm
saying I'm gonna evolve I'm gonna grow
so it's not Reinventing it's if you're
learning what I learned as I learn it
I'm just I'm growing once I learned this
business was whack I did another one you
know and I said and I'm gonna go do art
my midlife crisis was running around the
world opening up art galleries you know
I like to do fly cool like I been going
cool
I just like to do cool you know so I
don't I just think I and I got to be
smart about it like I got to be the plug
I got to be the connect so once I know
how to do it myself I could be real
arrogant about it and then I do it and
then when I win it's like when everyone
thinks you're losing and you win it's so
much better but who's making me an
underdore I was cracking up it's as
funny as hell you know what I'm saying
you know and I could be patient I think
I'm gonna do it by the pool you know
what I'm saying like I come out when I
feel like it you know it's never been
urgent I never found I've never felt my
Batman or the Joker I haven't found my
competition yet that inspires me to
fight I just feel like impressing my
girl and my family and me I don't even
feel no competition
I really don't I did the record label
thing years ago so I couldn't go back
and be like you know
pitching Nickels at me just because I
did it before no disrespect to the
company or to the music industry because
there's a lot of bread there since I did
it so you know the expectations of
myself is to do something that you know
fits the levels that I should be at and
what I noticed was you know number one
we were Outsourcing so much shooting
music videos and we making the clothes
and you know you know I like to make
movies it just made sense for me to have
my own television network and you know
when the internet hit because I'm always
looking for Independence I was like oh
[ __ ] I could do it and I didn't feel the
need to Outsource like I always feel
like a Johnny if I'm paying somebody to
do something I know I could do myself
like I always feel like the plug I can
grow that I ain't buying it from you
I'll go in the seller to you know that's
my Approach on things so I also feel
that I'm also really good at making
films so because I could make films make
move I understand the game I really like
ran the cash register there and because
I have a business mind I'm gonna invest
in that I tried to bring everybody that
was like kind of doing it at the time
I'm not gonna say no names but if you
know every name I'm talking about put
them in a room raise the money and one
just would not do it it was just like
why don't we want to have that power
it's like the more power we give each
other people start to think they're
taking away from themselves right it's
like people don't understand when you
share all of us together a way stronger
than us being alone you know I mean an
army is always better than a singular
person if they're all in the same sheet
of paper everyone can always equally win
because that way you could never lose if
I borrow a little bit from everybody in
this room I'm rich so I'm Gonna Keep
y'all rich as my friend so you can make
sure because I spend all my money so I
can make sure I'm right you know I need
a favor you know what I'm saying like
the only purpose for me to make everyone
that I made famous is so that they can
help me without putting up a dollar so
if it really comes down to it Jay I need
you to Instagram that yo Kanye just do
that it don't cost a dollar to Twitter
something out for me all I need is for
you to leverage your celebrity it
doesn't cost you a dollar just bring
attention to my brands that's what I
made you famous for if we stick together
that way we cannot lose I haven't had my
big deal yet
you know I'm trying to get a Billy
that's why I kind of keep betting it all
because the money has been short for me
I've been like this ain't it so you know
that's why I'm telling you I'm still on
the Block grinding I'm still flipping
because this ain't it what I made I
can't put up
I can't look at it you know or I'll
spend it I have spending habits I like
good things so I haven't got that deal
yet
you know what I mean you know like it's
all relative like you know if you're in
the street the first time you get a bird
it's a big deal like oh [ __ ] I got a
bird you know that's that's the success
of uh for like someone in music like
getting on the radio might be the
biggest deal but then you know or the
first time you get a tour bus or the
first time you perform at the Garden you
know there's so many different things so
like things that I thought were big once
I get them poor they're not big to me no
more like once you make your first
million like man quickly like that
wasn't nothing that can't be big
I did too much too young to give it up
to even be impressed with myself yet
honestly every single second of my life
is meant and everyone else's life I
think
it's meant to be a learning experience
so when something happens that didn't go
the way you wanted it to
you look at what you learned from it
right and there's been businesses that I
got completely robbed for short paper
but what I learned from it protected me
from getting robbed for big paper
you understand what I'm saying so at the
end of the day
I'm so happy
in this very moment I'm so happy
like
scary happy
you know I mean I think that's like the
misconception in the matter in the
middle in the middle of a pandemic all
my dreams are coming true
which is crazy to me
so I would have to say
if there was anything that would stop me
from being this happy now or that would
change if it's like is there anything I
could have done that could have made me
as happy as I am now
I'm happy now because every decision
that most people thought would be tough
every business I walked away from every
person I walked away from every person
that I punished that everyone told me
not to
from a Leo Cohen to a Harvey Weinstein
I'm glad I did it
I'm glad I was in a position to do it
I'm glad I'm that guy that these guys
are known to be bullies and I bullied
them
I'm the bully of bullies
I'm happy about that so
I love the fact that these challenges
and these tests have presented
themselves to me and I could get in the
shower I'm like damn I really am a
superhero I never ever waver when it
comes to honor never have I've walked
away from people that no one would walk
away from I balked on people that no one
would bark on until everyone is walking
on it I did it alone look at me and use
me as an example
um like you've seen that people have
tried every way they can to discredit
everything about me from my pocket to my
girls to everything you know what I'm
saying to my family like everything
everything and you see that when I'm
actually doing things that are good
people try to say I'm doing things that
are bad but at the end of the day I
haven't had to come outside right I
haven't had to come out of pocket and do
something that was kind of like you know
against what my morals and my principles
are I've been able to maintain being My
Own Boss sustain a certain kind of
lifestyle and all because my work is
good so if your work is good and you're
honorable it doesn't matter what's going
on around you you got to keep your head
down and move forward because all the
negativity is all a test to see if it
will distract you right but like again
if you know it's raining outside and
somebody tells you it's not you're like
yo I don't care what you say I'm
bringing an umbrella right I don't care
what you say you could call me a clown
and all that other stuff I already know
because I have this thing where I look
to my future right I don't look and I
don't to see like you know how it starts
I want to know how it's going to finish
right so I'm always doing that right and
I always see what I want my life to be
and I make sure it's that right and then
I architect that and then no like it'd
be people that have no plan that aren't
doing anything are the most distracting
right they're the ones that speak the
loudest because if you're doing
something you don't have time to be
worried about somebody else right you
don't have time for jealousy if you're
doing something you're too tired doing
what you're doing right so if you're
sitting around thinking that means you
should be doing some action right so
that's your fault so then the
overcompensation comes for blaming
somebody else for the reasons why you
don't want to move I'm not that dude
that says if you do this this will
happen and then it doesn't happen you're
just sitting around waiting you do the
right thing in my in my world you do the
right thing like if his dream was
literally to sit and play his album for
Kanye I watch the dream come true which
it was and it happened in a week only
because you did the right thing right
you know if his dream like he said his
dream is to sit here and doing it I I
that happened because he listens respect
will make your dreams come true and
respect is not convenient it's not when
it feels good as when it makes you
uncomfortable when you know someone
feels like damn I don't agree with him
but because I respect him I'm gonna do
what he says anyway that's respect and
I'm not going to say a word about it
what's your theory behind it having
multiple different Avenues working at
the same time okay Imagine This
imagine your number one artist after his
first album saying I quit
that's Jay-Z
quit after what do you mean he retired
after reasonable that's supposed to be
his first and last album did he yeah
it's supposed to be it's supposed to be
his person 15 albums later yeah so
you know from that day I was like well I
ain't depending on this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna build the roster what
how long did he retire though like it
was like a month he had I don't know
volume one didn't retire a big pass he
just passed it in value how many
retirements did this [ __ ] a lot all
right you know I lost count how many
times so that that I don't even care
that pushed you that pushed you to just
diversify yeah it was like 19.
damn that was that young it wasn't only
that it was just that I was a guy that
just thought I could do everything
better
so I was like I'm fresher than Ralph
Lauren I know it I met this [ __ ] I'm
fresher than him
I know I am I know I'm cooler than
Harvey Weinstein you know what I'm
saying I don't shook this [ __ ] down you
know what I'm saying you're not the only
one it's my little man
you know I see what Charlie you know all
these dudes Charlie walks and Leroy
Cohen's I'm like this [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying y'all scared of him it's
my little man some people try to dumb
you down as a distraction just because
they just don't want to they don't want
to work people are so scared of thinking
and so scared of action you understand
what I'm saying and that's what I'm
about I'm about thinking things through
an action they don't have the
wherewithal to see their ideas into
fruition and to be tangible and to be
real they and they don't they don't
think that getting to where they want to
go is going to be difficult Health it's
difficult it's huge it's boxing it's
getting punched in and face to win yeah
that's what it is you know to practice
you're hitting that bag but you're
getting hit like you got a spa to get
where you got to go so you're gonna feel
broke you're gonna have to feel anxiety
and if that doesn't make you feel
comfortable then it's going to be hard
to be an entrepreneur but you got to
know when you get in the game that
you're going to get tackled you got to
get up you got to work wounded you got
to stay positive you got to care about
your other people and sometimes most of
the times before you care about yourself
I only like to be around cool people
I I've always art detected my bubble
I only want to be around cool opinion
leaders like-minded people
and I filter and I edit people you have
to have a point of view and you have to
have a voice and you have to be
Unapologetic and when you do that you
don't stand in a crowd because most
people just want to fit in just being
different is a win in this world
everyone is just only feels confident in
a crowd so when someone does stand out
it's different I don't have time to be
worried because I'm always like if I
feel something's giving me anxiety I go
fix it right or else if I let it Rest in
Me You internalize it it causes like
sickness and cancer yeah so that's
another thing is you know I laugh a lot
yeah you know what I'm saying you know
me I I don't I my every day is therapy
because I hold nothing yeah and what
people have to understand is if you hold
it in when you go to therapy you're
gonna have to get dark before you get
light anyway that's therapy yeah so the
reason why I get dark real fast is so I
could get like Lightroom you know what
I'm saying yeah so I could be like you
know what I'm saying right I don't hold
no luggage right you know I mean like
when people ask me questions I'm gonna
answer it yeah
but ain't gonna [ __ ] my day up yeah like
just in that moment you're asking about
Flex yeah I got like you know
if you bit with the entrepreneur bug
you're always going to want more
but self-care is important make sure you
get some sleep
and make sure you celebrate yourself
and make sure you're enjoying yourself
you know I'm a firm believer and I would
never do anything and get paid for it
unless I would do it for free
so you didn't pay me for this but I
could get paid for this what I'm telling
you is this by me saying do not perform
over track like I got to see a live show
like I have a whole 5 000 square foot
facility where you can rehearse before I
could even co-sign you that's actually
educating until with the fundamentals of
hip-hop with the fundamentals of real
music is and a lot of people cannot step
up to that challenge because it feels
different right well you have to
rehearse it's like eight hours a day to
get good it's not anything easy that you
can't hide you cannot hide and you know
also you can't trust everyone's sound
system so if the track doesn't play
corrected with the mic it sounds
terrible and you never want your music
to be heard terrible your purpose of
performing live is so people want to be
vested in you and buy your merch and you
know keep a connection with you so you
have to show 100 be prepared at all
times and if you're not prepared like
you get a hit record tomorrow and you've
never done a show but you're gonna have
to perform at the radios like you know a
Summer Jam where there's 50 000 people
and you come out there unprepared you're
getting boo that can end your career a
bad show I care about people to a
certain extent but I can't care about
you when you care about yourself I can
bring you awareness and I can leave you
with that but I'm up in the hills bro
like you know I don't see it all here I
choose to help because I love because I
love myself see unless you love yourself
you don't know how to love nobody else
period right you can't tell me how to
love if you don't love yourself just
like you can't tell me how to get money
if you ain't got nothing you know what
I'm saying you can't tell me to be at
peace if you're not at peace you want to
help everybody else but you grounded I
don't understand it focus on yourself so
that you can really help somebody and
that's the problem with people they try
to use that as an excuse so many people
I say what's your dreams are to help
people but you crack broke what's that
your dream should be not to be to take
care of your children and make sure your
girl is taking care that's your dream so
that they never have to work and then
you go help everybody with the money you
made but it hurts you to help people
Independence is priceless it's just
people that have never had it don't even
understand and I don't even expect them
to you know and Independence means
usually putting up your own bill
you have to put up your own way that's
independence if someone else is putting
up the money that's dependence you
understand what I'm saying now you got
to move when they say move you have to
ask you have to be nice you have to
laugh at jokes that aren't funny you
know what I mean you have to be around a
racist and let them say little things
little cute things a nerd square that
wouldn't survived in the street and
Independence is like being
[Applause]
like let me tell you the perspective of
someone that's independent
if there's like a
a wild dog and he has to literally eat
the food he kills he cannot eat unless
he kills something that day
and then there's a dog that's changed he
lives in a house but he has three Square
males a day he got to do tricks he gets
petted he gets kicked out he gets beat
he got to get walks he walks on a leash
when that dog comes in the room with the
Wild dog the Wild dog is laughing he
doesn't care that you're in a mansion he
doesn't care that you eat steak every
day he still thinks she ever heard he
knows he can take from you because he
knows he has to kill every day to eat
you know what I mean and that's a
confidence that's a rock star and that's
the one thing that I know I would never
give up you know the ability to be that
like I laugh at anyone that's a caged
dog
you know walked on a leash told one to
eat and does tricks and rolls over for a
check why is it so hard to bet on
yourself for a lot of people like what's
the hardest why why is that so hard for
people to do it to pull up their own
money and bet on themselves because when
they see it really works out eventually
because when you put up your money
that's a struggle
and a lot of people don't just want to
walk into a struggle I know it's like
some people don't even though they could
fight they're not really you know have
the discipline to go to training camp
and really focus and and see it through
and like they don't want to walk into
the to the struggle to win you have to
to wonder when means you have to Embrace
pain you have to embrace struggle you
know what I'm saying like you have to
know that nothing's going to be easy in
order to be the best at it in the world
you have to do it and push yourself
where most people won't you know what
I'm saying you got to be up for that man
you know what I'm saying like you if you
up for it you could do it but not
everybody's up for it not everybody
really conceptually they want it but do
they want the pain the text to go get it
right and I have a lot like there's
people that like there's things about
them I don't like but I respect the fact
that they're gonna fight to get what
they want the fight and regardless of
whether our perspective is different and
not that fight every time whether it's
wrong right you're a person that fights
the hardest wins you really believe in
yourself and you work hard at it you'll
achieve it the question is am I ready to
work so hard that I'm better than
everyone else you understand what I'm
saying and you have to answer that
question within yourself am I ready to
embrace all the pain that nobody else
wants to embrace yeah am I ready to
really work harder and do it so much
that I'm better at it than everyone that
does it it's really about the work
effort really it's a professional work
ethic you can't just be good at
something you have to be able to to see
things through and do the things that
you don't enjoy it's not really about
the things that you enjoy that's the
easy part it's the things you don't
enjoy that's the things that people
usually shut down about they just don't
like it it's just because you don't like
something doesn't mean it's a failure
what I do is I'm a businessman right in
any business the more crowded it is the
harder it is to do it so I never want to
hustle on a crowded block so regardless
of what I'm always looking to do
something that nobody's doing so a lot I
was looking is was what's the next wave
logically if just logically I was paying
attention you know what I'm saying so
once I realized that I was like it's the
internet this Freedom was ridiculous and
plus like it was like damn if I know how
to make myself like content is like
currency it's the thing that makes money
forever and ever so it's like it's like
when somebody smokes joint the weed is
gone you got to grow more weed when
somebody looks at something you can pay
over and over again to see it and you
ain't got to keep making it I just look
at what people pay for and do it myself
I'm the plug I'm never a customer do it
yourself and leverage your own celebrity
right so instead of letting somebody
else make it we make it and then we
don't have to pay for the marketing it's
easy so now that I'm a brand for doing
that I can now completely invest in
myself but there's two games one is
making good work and one is leveraging
celebrity right the good work you ain't
got to move good work they find you you
ain't got to promote your destination
when you ain't doing too good that's
when there's the overcompensation you
still have the red carpets every day and
doing other it's a distract the fact
that you have no Talent confidence and
not giving a is the it makes you so Lean
Like Don't Give A factor that makes it
where you don't care what people think
you never feel like you're being judged
you never want to be a part of a crowd
and you just you know you just Fearless
about the way you feel about things you
know and then also you got swag you know
you just you just do what you want
regardless of what people think and it
feels good it's tough you know what's
time initially well when you when you
when you're brand new to Independence
it's a mindset it's a mind State it's a
tough mind State depends on what you
value as wealth right like if you value
your freedom and your happiness as
ultimate wealth or if you value
perception and physical things as
ultimate wealth you're either gonna like
physical things is temporary so you're
gonna hustle for the temporary or you're
going to hustle for the forever your
soul is forever absolutely you know you
don't want to cash that out you know
what I'm saying for temporary thing for
physical you know what I mean I think
that's the ultimate test it's like yo
you're gonna really be wealthy meaning
are you gonna be happy are you going to
look happy you understand you're going
to worry about how people see you and
buying physical things that make you
look better than you are or do you
really want to really feel good how do
you want to make money
this is what I do right take yourself to
five years where do you want to be in
five years see the thing about it is to
shoot a movie you need a script right
you can't just freestyle it you can't
say I want to say this or kind of like
that you have to be very direct and then
you put all your energy to what you want
you visualize it and then it has to
happen I'm a filmmaker so you want to
make movies yeah I want to make I mean
I've done that but I want to do it to
where I don't have to worry about a
regular job yeah this is the way I would
do it so I would make as many short
films as I can just so people can start
seeing that you're good I would star in
the movie If I want to be in on this
short film like a real artist is someone
that's damn near obsessed with it like a
painter should be painting eight hours a
day a band should be rehearsing eight
hours a day if you're a businessman you
should be doing your business eight
hours a day so if you're focused on
something and you're doing it eight
hours a day then you're doing it at a
professional level but you got to know
what you focused on and then you can
take things into your own control it
doesn't happen overnight it's not easy
expect pain expect anxiety expect
everything to go wrong and just be cool
breathe easy and then just see it out
because a lot of people start but don't
finish when things don't happen the way
it's never gonna happen the way you want
it to happen ever and if it does do not
trust it it's the devil there's so many
amazing talents of performers that came
out
of in the late 80s and
she's Mary J Big E Jay-Z the thumb
Wu-Tang and you were like a big part of
that did you realize at the time how big
that movement was going to be and then
what it was going to mean for the rest
of the world and the rest of the music
scene yeah I did I did you could feel it
at the time yeah every I knew that
that's why I was the person that was
documenting everything because I knew
everything I was doing in that moment
was legendary so the way I would look at
it would be like damn could you imagine
if you had Jimi Hendrix and David Bowie
and John Lennon before they cracked or
Mick Jagger in like a studio or just
kicking it before they got famous and
then imagine when they did so because I
was so confident in everything I was
doing and all the people around me I
knew that what we were doing would
probably set the stage for history you
know what I'm saying I didn't think
anybody was cooler than us and I knew it
actually and it you know turned out I
was right you know in all of them I'm
from Harlem he had a crew called the
best out
and we sit though parties and um at the
Cotton Club we had to take the pre DJ
and we used to make t-shirts and we had
our names on them and we used to have
basketball games and a lot of people
tried to do what we were doing we were
emulated like I remember when we were
throwing our basketball games would be
like us the best out versus kept child's
who they were called boss and it was
crazy at the Gaucho gym and then the
next thing I would see puff do a
basketball thing but you know it ended
up being tragic but I knew that he was
influenced by what we was doing so I've
always so seen how my influence has been
on the rest of the world from day one
and it still is like that people still
you know take what I do and they're
influenced by it that's why I think at
this point in my life at 46 it's
important to do things that are positive
so are people going to emulate what I'm
doing to emulating something positive
like eating healthy like taking care of
yourself like being good to women and
taking care of your woman being a good
dad like loving your children like to me
that's ultimate wealth loyalty is not
convenient if you only you can't just be
loyal when it's like easy
like if there's a bag of money but you
got to do the wrong thing and be
disloyal to somebody when you walking oh
I don't robbing friends yeah you know
what I mean and just you know so
sometimes you know respect to me guides
you and and protects you from everything
if you if you leave with respect on on
anything the right things will happen
you understand I've never seen respect
put anyone In Harm's Way I've only seen
respect always always
um protect you and and then also the
ultimate test is always like to
disrespect the people you love to get
something physical like some bread you
understand what I'm saying that's the
test you know what I mean and tests
aren't meant to be easy
you know what I'm saying like that's
what my test would always be it would be
like am I gonna play my culture am I
gonna get that doubt you understand and
I just couldn't do it because I'm not
gonna tell my family as many times I'm
sure you could have played on the
channel yeah all the time you know that
was my problem with the music business
because it was such a a it was such a
disloyalty to my culture to exploit it
the way it was being exploited and
letting other cultures exploit it and
not saying that and then like it's all
right just because I'm making money so
just because I'm all right mix it up you
know because I I fought through it it
still didn't make it all right to just
sit there and watch them all the rest of
the culture to me that's what I always
fought for you know what I mean there
was like guilt with it always you know
what I mean just being around people I
didn't want to be around people make me
the underdog it's funny because they
don't understand what the game I'm
playing just because I'm not playing
your game or just because I'm not moving
at the pace you moving it don't mean I'm
wrong
you know what I'm saying your win ain't
the same win as mine and it's never been
like what I've always like when someone
thought a record there was dope I was
like a label deal you understand like
you got a record deal you should have a
lady you might have a TV show we should
have a network you know that's just how
I think I have boss thoughts I'm always
thinking
I don't know what's after right there
boss talks I don't calm down yes I don't
I don't know anything I don't I don't
know any other language but boss boss
language you know what I'm saying so
when people don't talk in Boston to me I
don't know what they saying you know
what I'm saying it's a language it's
just a problem like like people are
posting like bosses and people approach
things like workers a lot of people
don't want to be bossy because there's
so much responsibility that come with it
you understand they scared of it and I
always say that you understand what I'm
saying right but a boss only can think
about it in false terms so if somebody
says they want to get in business some
people might say well I need somebody to
give me a job that's not a broad story a
boss says if I'm gonna get business my
thought is if I want to get in business
I'm gonna create the business figure I'm
gonna buy the business you understand
what I'm saying then I'm gonna do the
business but I'm not trying to be hired
my Approach is always going to be bossy
you know someone that's not used to
being the boss his thought process ain't
bossy we don't have voice thoughts
fluent boss you understand what I'm
saying bro yeah before winning boss and
if you don't talk to me and boss I don't
understand what you're saying so we'll
be like huh and people will think you're
an [ __ ] because they'll be like no
that's not how I posted right you
understand what I'm saying that's I'm
not celebrating that that you got to do
your boss talk is like I speak that yeah
we speak that language you could tell
what somebody else talks boss yeah just
by their reports on things and someone
that talks Force doesn't speak any other
language
I only talk boss the minute I had
daughters I was like I got to change
everything I can't do anything to a girl
that I don't want another man to do to
my daughter so that was
the daughters for sure my daughter's
changed my life for my um second
daughter Cholula was born I decided to
quit everything to make sure that
anything I did I put her first not not
the business she before it was like
business first because I got to pay for
the kids but it's like if you're not
there to spend the money with your kids
it really doesn't matter they need you
and your company so and and I saw all
the things I was missing so you know
what do you think I'd rather do be on a
yacht porn champagne or a girl or taking
my daughter to get a cupcake it's
nothing better than taking your daughter
to get a cupcake you know there's
nothing better than watching your baby
smile you know so it's true you know but
I it's like seems obvious but you know
Lotto
is really like energy it's love it's not
like physical money which really doesn't
mean anything it's just how good you
make someone feel it's how good your
woman feels how good your children feel
like you got as much money as you know
billions of dollars but if you want
happy and you're lonely you broke if
your kids are unhappy you broke you know
if your woman's unhappy you broke it's
all about effort and what you can
visualize in your mind you know if you
can't think it could happen and if you
don't have confidence that it's gonna
happen it ain't gonna happen so if you
doubt yourself like you know I box or at
least I used to I'm not getting in the
ring unless I know I'm a win or else I
already lost and look at everything I do
like that I'm winning and it's a mental
game too it's 100 everything is about
perspective and what you consider away
you know some people
think they're winning because other
people think they're winning even though
they don't feel good about what they're
doing they're like oh you think I'm
winning so that must mean I'm winning
but I feel like that's not winning you
know you have to know what makes you
happy what you consider when not
everybody's winning is the same you know
what I'm saying for some people like to
fit in with JW or not me the reason why
people take jobs is because they got to
pay their bills when you say be a boss
or be independent everybody should be an
entrepreneurs everyone has an apartment
right
you're the boss in your apartment right
no matter what no matter how little it
is if it's whether it's a big house or a
little house that space right there
you're the boss that's what your
business is that's what your life is you
create the space so you can control it
you control your environment but you
have to Art detect that you want to live
in a house build it you know what I'm
saying nobody gonna give it to you but
once you get in that house I don't care
if the president or whoever it is anyway
he walk in my house Obama you still got
to listen to me in this house people
think it's safe to have a job but if
somebody could find you how is that safe
right period like you got to be nice to
somebody if they don't like you they can
fire you and if they the people that
could fire you don't be owning this
neighbor they be supervisors so then it
becomes like political there's no
politics when you're in the boss it's my
way or no way because I believe that you
see that at any point no matter how much
you contribute that whole thing can be
taken away at any particular time right
so how does somebody then go and just
make that shift to the same they're
doing for somebody else do it for
yourself right if you're a paid editor
edit your own movie you're a paid writer
right at your own man giving you know
it's like the thing is nobody ever gave
me anything no one gave me real no
record deal I had to do it myself so
imagine if I would have waited for a
deal for Jay-Z there'd be no Jay-Z
there'd be no Kanye there'd be no Lee
Daniels there'd be no Kevin Hart there'd
be no Rachel Roy none of that you know
what I'm saying none of them anything I
had to build all that like No One's
Gonna hire me to direct you know what I
mean No One's Gonna hire me to be the
CEO of a company I made the company I'm
the CEO of it what I find is a lot of
people are really insecure about
themselves they don't think they're as
interesting as they are so many people
be so quick to make money of other
people's experience you know but you got
your own like what's the purpose of that
it makes no say that again yeah and
that's what I had to do that's what you
had to do right once we started to
believe in ourselves we just work a
little harder but you end up reaping all
the benefits on it on your own terms and
it feels 100 good and you can control
the people you around and it makes the
most sense I wanted to capitalize
capitalize with everything I thought I
was the best at so I thought I was the
best at dressing I didn't think nobody
could dance better me so I thought I
knew where hit records I knew I had the
best multiple authentic experiences so I
knew I'd make the best movies and I just
wanted to do all those things but in
hindsight I just like to do it because I
like to be fun I'm really creative yeah
you know what I mean I just like to be
artistic freely and you know it's like I
don't know I just I just I just like
don't I just thought you know like I
just I'm having so much fun and you know
when you get success relatively young
it's like you know you can settled but
then you're gonna get bored so you know
I was a mobile when I was in my 20s so I
was like I'm able to go do fashion I
want to know I want to run around the
world I wanted everything I see or hear
about I want to see it personally I want
to live it I want to know what I want it
experience when I want to spend every
kind of bread how do you feel about
Rockefeller today is it the same
attitude that I think it's a shame it
doesn't exist anymore you know I think
the way that it dissolved was kind of
selfish but I ain't gonna get into that
you know what I'm saying but it would
have been nice to see everybody doing
well as opposed to one person and that's
the way I wanted Rockefeller I made it
you know I believe in the circle of
success where everybody gets rich I
don't want to make employees I want to
make bosses yeah it's more of a family
and surprise well it was you know but
then it turned out to be one person
stayed rich and everyone else had to
work for him and that's not how I looked
at Rockefeller and what I realized is I
need to make and invest in things that I
could pass to my family so I had to
invest more in myself as opposed to
investing in other people because not
everybody has the same idea idea
ideology as me you know what I'm saying
not everybody you know looks at things
the same way so you know I should have
probably paid a little more attention in
making assets that I own as opposed to
making other people because my thing was
I was putting people in power so that
they could put us in power but every
time I put somebody in power they would
shut the door and they just wanted all
the power people got hungry as soon as
they get it's just human nature it's how
men are the testosterone in them that's
why I also surround myself more with
women because women don't tend to be so
jealous do you think that's more of an
exclusively male thing then other
females on aren't as like hungry when
they get in that position I think males
are so supremely insecure that they turn
into clowns a lot a lot of people cheat
and try to
cut on to it that's the only way I want
to win at it I don't want to cheat to
get there because then I didn't win at
my game I actually lost you actually
lost you know what I'm saying but you
know I'm not gonna play your game I only
play my only cheat when you don't fully
believe in your abilities in the first
place yeah it's over compensation yeah
for sure yeah but then that's like a
different kind of win you know you play
in a different game I have bigger dreams
than trying to be getting a salary from
some company you know I need to own
something I need Legacy you know like
the dashes are going to be they are I
already know it we're gonna be like the
Kennedys and and the Vander you know
we're going to be an upstanding family
you already are that's what I mean
that's what I'm saying I want it easy
for my kids and I want it easy for my
kids kids and that's all I'm doing right
now and just making sure that the
company can run when I'm not around you
know what I'm saying family and Company
that's what that's what that's what you
know it has to be able to sustain
everybody says they want to be the boss
but people be scared to be the boss most
people are scared to put up their own
money most people are scared to tell
people to work when they don't want to
most people are scared to even ask for
their money you understand what I'm
saying like people I've seen people that
are uncomfortable about asking about
their own business like asking for
change you know what I'm saying or
asking how much do you get paid or when
am I going to get paid or where's my
money
I had never felt uncomfortable about
asking for my bread and I've never
understood people that were
uncomfortable for asking for their bread
and I really don't understand people
that are offended by you asking for your
bread right you know you ask somebody
for their money and they're like what
you asking like I'm not supposed to ask
for my money I'm not supposed to ask
about my money like the money and the
business there's no motion with asking
about it because it's business there
should be no fear you should never be
ashamed to ask for your change ever you
know or to scrutinize a bill after my
daughters were born I shut down
everything I was doing I invested all my
money into at Rachel Roy and then I just
opened up art galleries where creative
people could come and coexist and make
things happen without
um compromise the quality of living so I
opened up DD 172 which was a 10 000
square foot Gallery in the most
expensive Real Estate in Manhattan in
Tribeca and you know I had people like
most deaf and Jay Electronica and Wiz
Khalifa and currency and it just goes on
rock and roll The Black Keys you know uh
Holy Ghost
um Erica Badu all performing I had an
internet television station called
creative control this was in 2009. we
have chapters in our life you know the
cool thing about the way I approach
things is I always have like a ill
bucket list you know what I'm saying and
there'll be there's a bunch of things
that I want to do in my life and
eventually I know I'm gonna do it okay
so young I wanted to hustle I got that
off my bucket list quick you know what
I'm saying I wanted to be a music Mobile
off my bucket list I wanted to be a
fashion Mogul off my bucket list I
wanted to sell oil off my bucket list I
wanted to have art galleries off my
bucket list and the things that were
like on my bucket list with things like
I'd be like even though you saw it in
the book one day I'm gonna do a diabetes
Network I'm gonna do something that's
just about diabetes I did it yeah it's
off my bucket list you understand what
I'm saying one of the things on my
bucket list is the on the football team
one of my things on my bucket list is to
have a network you know a real Channel
to have a hotel so there's always like a
chapter in my life where I attack that
bucket list one of the things on our
bucket list is to grow land you
understand what I'm saying and to be
able to have a farm I was trying to grow
cotton make the clothes from the cotton
it'd be high completely right that's
what we were trying to do in North
Carolina because you made it this far in
the video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome if you want to see the last
one-on-one I did with Gary vaynerchuk
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there I'm talking about
something that the world thinks is a
contradiction I don't understand why
anybody should ever verbally dress down
an employee